hello everybody my name is markiplier
and i'm very tired i'm gonna go into the
ocean
and i'm going to
[ __ ] lixie and roll it back i don't know
what i'm talking about this is iron lung
i meant to play this a long time ago and
then i got lost in space uh if you
haven't seen in space with mark blair
you should check it out link in the
description it's on my channel page you
don't check with the front page of my
channel every day then you don't know
what i'm doing
let's see and restart this hi my name is
markiplier welcome to iron lung i'm
going to go into the ocean
i'm a
[ __ ] poseidon decades ago every known
star inhabited
oh my god
lixian make me seem like a coherent
human being every known star inhabitable
planet vanished leaving only those who
were on space stations or starships this
event became known as the quiet rapture
with supplies dwindling and
infrastructure crumbling survivors are
searching for any trace of natural
resources in a universe of barren moons
lit by the ghost light of vanished stars
one such moon holds a strange anomaly an
ocean of blood you are a convict tasked
with exploring this anomaly in a
makeshift submarine nicknamed the iron
lung it was not designed for this depth
so you will be welded inside and a
forward window will be closed there is
no time for training if successful you
will earn your freedom wow
if its blood just drink the blood
blood's got resources in it here's a
scientific breakdown of all the
materials that are in blood
look at all these so i'm assuming that
if you found blood you're gonna be
a-okay i don't know how to extract
resources out of blood but i'm gonna
find out also interesting concept about
the idea that just like oh here i go
then
i am
cruising depth in roughly 40 seconds
standby
so you say i have not been trained for
this
um i'm seeing some voltage
irregularities in the instrument so keep
an eye out for sparks or flames or
anything like that i can't i how do i
i don't see any sparks
uh the whole feeling it but it's still
holding strong
well it better be
quoting
what do you oh
okay thank you
we're starting to lose range of signal
you'll be a crew step soon so
be careful
you're on your own
i'm on my i guess i'm on my own okay tab
briefing two weeks ago we conducted an
exploration of moon 85 for the first
time since the quiet rapture leading to
the discovery of the fourth blood ocean
a fourth one two three fourth you found
three others of these and this is the
fourth one what happened to the convicts
that you sent down into the other three
blood oceans are they okay am i that one
i don't think so i have no training your
task is to photograph these points of
interest with the sm-13s forward camera
photos must be taken within two units of
the specified position and 10 degrees of
the specified angle you can also use the
camera to help with navigation only
photos taken at the specified points of
interest will be saved since you can
navigate by site pay attention to your
coordinates and consult the map the
proximity indicators next to the sub
controls will trigger if you're getting
too close to an obstacle good luck
thanks
um
what
hello ah
this is not an expedition it is an
execution when they put you in here they
don't want you to return and even if you
do and even if they keep their promises
what freedom waits for you a few dying
ships in a sea of dead stars if there is
still hope it lies beyond the veil
hoping this void is as illusionary as
the starlight i will choose to breathe
my last year at the bottom of an ocean
unseen unheard and uncontrolled they
will get their execution and i will get
my freedom okay so i'm assuming this is
from one of the explorations of the
other three blood oceans how [ __ ]
cool does a blood ocean sound
not at all when i'm in it
where am i
i've heard node information okay
x325 741.88
18. well this is why the universe
imploded they didn't name the z-axis
with a z so i seem to be at 182
116. okay 182 116. that would put me at
182 116. so i'm starting right here
bearing north okay so that's good to
know so i need to go up to
stay in the 175 range and i need to get
to y200 this seems pretty easy
well let me just quickly whoa that was
turning i did not mean to do that
damn it okay my oxygen is doing okay
i don't know what this is all about
oh
[Music]
is that a picture of the outside well
that's not good well i don't like this
and i don't like that i really don't
like this at all actually but i know
what i'm doing so i'm just gonna go yeah
i should be fine all the way up i just
need to start turning it around uh 175.
bearing uh probably about 15 degrees
starting at 175
on my mark three
two one mark
is my name oh that's way more than i
thought
okay let's see if there's anything new
here
what are we looking at
all right forward camera shows nothing a
few scraggly plant life possibly at
least that's what i'm hoping
not a lot of light down here might be
souls of the damned at the bottom but
what do i know i'm one of them
all right bearing
16.68 degrees due north north east uh
moving forward to
200 y
on my mark mark
and ceasing momentum we're now 200 y
which means that we need to do bearing
uh 90 degrees due east
uh straight shot to the anomaly roger
roger here we go
all right we can we can actually be a
little bit uh under it because we might
scrape a little bit if we go too low but
i mean i'm at 200 so i should be fine
all right we need to go to uh
x 300 roger roger on my mark here we go
is that the proximity center because i'm
not exactly worried about that because i
know that i'm doing okay
yeah we're fine oof
all right we should be fine i'm not
worried about it
we're gonna be okay i'm at y200 it's
just a passing obstacle
no worries about that no no no it's all
fine
thank you
all right we are 50 meters away from
marking x 300
and
bearing up on x 300 in three two
one
mark all right we made it to x 300 we
need to go three two two so if we drop
bearing by about
was that 35 degrees
so 125
do
east east south
and we're cruising to why 186
and
322 roger utter engaging
what is that sound
i think that's just a hall undulating
under the pressures of the blood
all
right
three two two coming up on it
getting real close we need 186
322 roger
very close very close
all right
uh we should be right up on it honestly
i'm sorry do i need to be at a certain
depth i notice this is a
33
but i'm not exactly 100 sure what that
means i don't think i can drop the depth
down either way i'm not i'm not quite
there anymore i need 322y 186 so i'm
still a little bit off
you know
cruise a little more south
wham this should be it
oh are you talking angle i see what you
mean
angle 33 that's what the a is roger
a33 adjusting to angle of 33 degrees
close enough and capturing
oh
well that's a thing
i don't know what that thing is but it's
a thing did i get credit for that did i
ah i got credit for that all right roger
uh anomaly located at 322 186 a 33
degrees uh has been located seems to be
some uh
tombstones of some kind maybe teeth if
it's if i'm really scared for my own
safety uh if if i'm feeling horny
probably dildos uh but i'm gonna go with
the
dildo tombstones i am scared and horny i
am marking that as complete i need to
bear about 15 degrees off of north
north northeast 15.
uh
i could probably even approach i've got
some unclear readings over here on the
eastern wall of whatever feature i am
glancing at
i need to approach to 378 270 263 roger
roger okay bearing actually the
bearing's good let me just knock off a
few bits off of that
and
uh 370 378 263 confirmed all right here
we go you know this is ship ain't too
bad
this ship ain't too bad it's kind of
cozy when you really think about it all
right saving progress that's probably a
good sign
378 263
approaching
uh
approaching too
much on the y-axis knocking off some
degrees there
continuing progress
uh making
more significant adjustment of
trajectory
uh reducing that a bit i think 45 might
be the way to go on that
all right approaching uh we have now
crossed where we need to be on the y we
got to make some uh reverse
progress here because i'm very dumb so
i'm gonna go hard 90 degrees over until
i reach my destination to try to reduce
my uh my dumbness and increase my iq a
little bit all right on my mark and here
we go
we're going to
378 approaching and three two one mark
all right and the angle is 50 degrees
roger roger reducing to 50 degrees
uh east
uh
northeast is what that would be bam
capturing
now what do we have here
okay um
yeah i don't know what i'm looking at
houston um seems to be again some kind
of teeth uh
maybe some thin dildos maybe some
tombstones for some really tall people i
seem to be like something some kind of i
see like a pattern of what might be a
skull behind it with the teeth said in
the bottom there and like an eye in the
background there um
got a bad feeling now i'm looking at an
angler fish of some type
but i'm gonna consider myself lucky
uh that i didn't walk into that trap all
right next up is 259 406 we got a narrow
passage but if i'm hitting this
calculating the angle it's not quite a
45 degree from my current position um
yeah 45 degree actually 45 degrees
should be able to get me through there
if i go up to 350 off of 275 350. if i
approach clear 45 degree angle opposite
of north uh on the other side north here
dropping down to
wow i can't do math 360
315.
so if i hit three
hold on just a second houston need to
take a picture or something that was
outside
okay cool all right
all right uh pretending i didn't hear
that and i'm adjusting it 315 degrees
and i'm going to be
progressing once again to 275 350 and on
my mark here we go
you know navigating through blood i
thought it would have been a little bit
more difficult yeah and for a
space-faring civilization
hold on you need to check something real
quick
yeah
okay
all right once again pretending like
that was nothing
to make myself feel better we are
currently at 347
295 we need 275 350. we are at actually
we're pretty close there um the only
thing i'm off of is the
well actually no wait no i'm nowhere
near i need to be never mind using
continuing on i need 275 350 on my mark
and mark
that's going to be fine houston it'll be
fine
path should be if we're at 3
29 329 we are off course because we are
already at 375 we need to adjust
just do let's do 300 degrees all right
and on my mark
we're fine oh my god we're fine
what what happened
oh i lost oxygen i think wait no yeah
i'm fine okay god all right
currently at 312 324
312 2324
uh we're still pretty close on that but
i think we're okay
approaching
275 as objective has dictated
don't like these sounds
all right 275
350 approaching the right wall
[Music]
don't like that sound
that's not what i would call a good
sound houston you hearing this lixian
you're in houston command do you hear
any of this
okay all right admission continue
mission as
as described thank you lixian i will not
let you down um approaching 259 406 at
angle 340
roger engaging
[Music]
i really don't like this
and approaching why 400
we're looking for 406 259 we're very
close to our objective
concerning say these are terrible sounds
that i'm hearing
oh interesting okay that must be
actually the objective that we're
looking for adjusting course just a bit
scooting forward just a bit
and taking second picture
all right a little more
let's get a better look at whatever the
hell this nonsense is
all right uh anomaly has not been
justified i should have just looked at
what angle it wanted it went 296. roger
296 confirmed
and
take a picture
seems to be the source of the sounds
that i'm hearing
could be some kind of intestinal
nonsense all right i'm not close enough
i see
all right we're looking
to oh 259 i see i see i see oops i'm
actually going the wrong way all right
and looking for 296 right
yep close enough
got a
picture uh
well still not good enough huh
[Music]
i i'm looking right at this thing
whatever it is i'm looking dead at it
[Music]
i could not be closer to this thing
i am looking straight at whatever this
is these intestinal tubes i'm looking
dead at them
all right fine but it really wants the
specified angle i think i think i got to
get this from another angle i'm kind of
off i'm 406 is where i should be in the
y
and x is 259. yeah that's what it wants
it wants me to look at it from a
different angle so i need 406.
then turn back
towards it
this is what it's looking for the 396 i
believe
taking picture
there we go now that looks like a oh you
son of a [ __ ] it's oh god the x is off
all right so if i back away from it
should be fine
all right that's a good picture of it
all right good picture confirmed
boogieing out of here i don't think that
that's a path there but hey maybe it is
i should probably give it a try huh all
right bearing 45 degrees roger straight
off this shot
going on the knob and i'm gunning it
straight over off of 45 degrees
confirmed roger uh moving up to
325 425 325 425 confirmed
all right we've reached 425 x trying to
adjust angle as we go so i can continue
forward uh no further than 350 please
we are not going to hit
340.
okay 350 has been achieved we will start
our right turn
making good progress carrying on a
little straighten out down
i need to hit 375 which is good
straight down from here going to
325
325 achieved uh making my way 90 degrees
due east
[Music]
and progressing forward to
fourth marker which is at x 560 straight
drop from here straight on and through
i'm gonna guess that's good sound and
i'm not gonna think about it too tightly
oh my god why why oh why why
why
what's going on
what is the deal what's the deal okay
there's nothing it's just
it's nothing
okay
five
fifty
approaching
450 feeling good mission log uh feeling
hungry actually all this thought of
blood is making me kind of yearn for
something primal and uh
throbbing between my teeth i was trying
to go for like eating a heart but it
sounds like i want to eat a dick and i
just want to reiterate it that's not my
true true
that's not my heart's truth uh
in all honesty i would like to to
consume a beating heart you know so i
can feel it pulsating between my lips
sounds sexy
what
what
what what
hey now
hey
now
you see we've reached uh roughly 5 40.
i'm turning due north to see what the
hell was just blink blocking on my ass
over there
um taking a gander out the camera yep as
confirmed sees nothing gonna adjust
south south east uh
make my way down to way
point four y two two seven confirmed
all right adjusting course a little more
east
making my way to 560.
and two two seven two seven seven
two seven seven actually we have made it
we just need to now go
straight x off to 560. that's 90 degrees
uh
engaged
all right we've reached our destination
looking at it at angle 43 degrees
confirmed 43 degrees locked in
progress good taking picture
uh
okay well all this is just
digital noise here
well clearly i'm looking at the black
mesa logo um lexi and if you just
overlay a black mesa logo on top of that
you'll see that's exactly what it is we
found the remains of black mesa
half-life 3 confirmed all right engaging
uh engines down to x613y197
uh do angle is roughly
about 60 degrees which means 90 plus 60
150 degrees confirm
making my way down to uh way point five
uh looking for x 6 17 197 confirmed
feeling pretty good about this mission
you know feeling pretty good i think i'm
gonna earn my freedom and uh
everything's looking good for me
oh my god what i didn't know i
i didn't know that was actually a thing
what am i on the invincible
hey all right
613 197
all right y197 has been reached we're
going uh
now angling over
90 degrees x
uh to reach um
[Music]
613 confirm
all right 639 has been reached angle 55.
roger that
55 degrees and confirmed
that's nice all right good picture has
been achieved we're looking for a choke
point over at 750 due to
uh
262. 750 262 angle is
approximately
maybe like 30 degrees up from 90. so
actually pretty close maybe actually it
gives me the angle that i need to go we
are moseying over to
750 262.
no problem so far houston we are
locked on course and feeling pretty
spicy
[Music]
all right 752 uh some some 260 okay
we've reached our y coordinate
apparently the angle that i thought it
was going to be has been misleading i'm
actually going to drop it down
continue on to 750.
oh that's not good okay 750 has been
achieved actually we need to go
now
actually 70 50 has been overachieved now
we jump up to about 275 there's going to
be a real tight squeeze here
we're trying to get to if we find the
right angle with both those wall we're
going to try to get to 802
go 286
800 286 yes
let me take a picture
okay i'm okay
okay
this is going really well
a64 258
a64 has been achieved
hey
who who's here
okay
hey 258 okay we're not quite there
[Music]
hey 260 258 okay
we're very close to obstacles here
we don't want to get too close
all right
258 oh wow this really nestled in here
all right angle 209
roger that 209 here we go take a picture
sure it'll be really fun to look at
oh
what am i looking at
wait wait a minute
are those windows what am i looking at
what am i looking at here
why does that look
why does that look like a road barrier
i swear those are windows like crazy
okay whatever
um not my problem i'm actually going to
back that ass up
straight out of here back up to uh 300
please oh yep yep yep i was right 300
please
all right actually we don't need full
300 we now need to get the hell out of
here
uh getting the hell out of here
confirmed all right houston we are uh
running for our life we
have [ __ ] our pants
um
we will need clean underwear once we
arrive
uh
back up to the surface i am gonna hit
something
yep uh hitting something confirmed uh
let's avoid please
where are we 8 37
oh whoops i think i'm nestling in this
little nook here let me back that ass up
a little bit
i think i made my turn a little too
early there
let's try that again
oh hi okay my god you gotta stop doing
that you gotta stop doing that
i don't like steam
i don't like steam tool
i'm getting out of here oh two still
looking good houston we are not facing
any delusions of grandeur except for how
great i am that is not delusion that is
just pure fact thank you very much
houston for listening to my last words
as i die beneath the blood
okay
houston
how you feeling handsome um
see word x uh
576y 355.
what
576 350. how did
that that's not possible
what do you mean that that's not how did
i
that
that is
that's quite literally impossible how
did i get here okay whatever i'm not
going to question a good thing i i guess
all right houston make my way up uh do
straight north now going to 400
uh
looking at 500 actually
i don't that doesn't make any sense how
did i get here
and what are those lovely noises on the
outside of my iron lung
are they going to kill me
i bet all right we've made it up to 460
approaching 500 once we hit 500 we'll
make a course correction do
about 70.
[Music]
i'm gonna start making that course
correction a little early houston um
approaching x uh or y500 uh looking at
525 about 520 uh 623 by 520 roger that
all right 6283 520 520-ish confirmed
looking at angle 63. roger roger here we
go
and taking a picture
yeah it's bones
i'm beginning to think my uh estimate of
uh tombstones and uh dildos wrong teeth
we're closer cuz teeth are technically
bones um still don't like what i'm
looking at gonna turn my tail and run
uh houston once again if you could get
the heavy duty underwear i'm going to
need that upon arrival thank you lixian
uh
you're the best 270 confirmed straight
on
looking for about uh 400 by five four by
five
what
is that the siren song of the
the ocean of blood siren
the sexiest siren of them all
i'm getting to think that's something i
should inspect
up nothing
as i suspected
on closer inspection turns out it was
nothing
still fine
also
it's just the uh
blood ocean uh french horn player
down here having a good old time
seemed to be some unidentified landmarks
of some kind
causing me a bit of a problem here but
uh nothing i can't handle he's nothing i
can't handle
all right
well usually we might have a bit of a
problem um
when you design this lyxian when it hits
the bottom one below this that means i
still got 25 left right that doesn't
mean zero
right
all right sure thing you got it pal
thank you very much we have reached x
400 we are looking to do a course
correction do
uh
northwest please uh confirmed
all right we are approaching
unidentified territory right about 360
365 x is where we want to be and then we
want to look at
uh just doing straight north after that
or
using landscape as a bit of a
identifier
maybe doing okay uh maybe a little too
much on the west side
straight north
all right passing through the channel
looks like pretty good we have uh 368
614 368 614 approaching the other
anomaly
i might want to hit this one first
though if i'm already at uh if i get up
to y650 i'm actually going to go for
this one first houston so i'm looking
for
y650
my 650 confirmed actually i probably
want y 660
666 confirmed
what is that oh my god
hey
whoa hey ho fire on the bridge um
well the light was kind of nice but i
don't know if fire is good i'm gonna go
ahead and say fire ain't good
uh
fire not good don't know how that
happened
all right
five six six six confirmed
all right six six zero
um locked in actually let's just keep it
at 6 59 let's go straight to 70 degrees
do dead west
dead west
and confirmed locking in going to
200 x 200
confirmed it's an awfully peaceful ride
actually when you really think about it
this is quite nice and i i do like it
it's uh
pretty good pretty good pretty good
all right still going for 200 we've got
about 80 meters left to go on the
journey um no alarms yet on the
proximity alert up and right on cue
we're looking at something on the north
side but i think we're going to be solid
if we keeps keep going straight
all right no matter what i hear i'm not
going to look over to my left or i don't
need to take a picture of whatever is
around me it's not important right now
we don't need to worry about that that's
not a big deal to me
i am just fine thank you we have
approached 200 we're going to
slippity-slap over a little more and
then we're going to take a sharp
downward turn
um kind of the slanting angle uh not
quite straight down and going forward
i seems to be a sound of something
something in front of me and i think i'm
gonna take a look
nothing
sure sounds like something
whoa
okay as long as we keep going this way
we should be okay
wow that sounds like a something
wow that really sounds like a something
huh
nothing
this ain't nothing it's a big old
nothing
we're trying to get to 550 somehow
oh no you don't okay well that's a
problem um
here's whoa
what am i looking at
do not know do not know also do not know
how i'm going to back out of this
okay
hey
hey now
hey now
yeah
okay
all right let's keep going i guess
this is getting really wibbly
okay we're looking at 180 576
we're getting real close to it
okay 576 hasn't been reached let's not
get too close
we got to go 180 apparently
hitting 90 degrees over there that
bearing and we've reached 180
and the angle is 184
all right i kind of already know what it
is because i can feel it jiggling my
blood 184 confirmed taking picture can't
wait to see this with my own eyes
well that's
a thing all right we got that in there
gonna try to not uh look at that anymore
we're gonna back that ass up straight
out of here
thank you for your time uh appreciate it
big preach across the board biggest
breach actually
straight back back this ass up out here
what happened
what happened what happened what what
happened what happened what happened
did we move again 2
two oh it got us out two seventy seven
three
i appreciate that all right course
correcting i don't know how that
happened but it did so thank you for
that
it's awfully convenient but i'm awfully
curious about why
all right making my way to 325 the 741
confirmed
approaching 325
on my mark three two one mark and slow
down
moving due north to
3
41 confirmed
approaching waypoint
and 341
right on the money okay and angle 18.
you got it big boy
take a picture
more bones by the look of it i'm gonna
guess that's more bones all right
houston we have gotten one two three
four five six seven eight nine nine uh
waypoints have been achieved i feel real
good about this houston we're gonna go
uh do about
maybe 120 degrees for a while till we
hit uh
y700
you got it
at least i got plenty of oxygen you know
it really sucked if i didn't
and approaching why 70321
mark all right why 700 has been achieved
let's go a little below let's go uh 690
690
321
mark
and then we're gonna do straight 90
degrees over
roger roger 8891 and cruising straight
east uh till x575
roger and mark
houston could i get some music
thank you
please tell me this is the last goodbye
why why whoah
okay um
we are at 460 690 uh cabin check looking
pretty good nothing on the scanners uh
this note has not changed to something
horrible
lots of squeaking going on but we seem
to be holding strong because we believe
in ourselves and uh self-confidence will
get you so far
still progressing to
550 roger that kind of curious what
they're gonna get out of this uh houston
what you're going to get out of this um
pictures of bones you know paleontology
and all that stuff is very cool and all
but uh
curious how we're all gonna celebrate
this one
looks like you were right about that 25
roger roger we are approaching 550 in
three two one mark all right we made to
550 we're gonna go straight
north at about 15 degrees off north
going to
750. y750 here we go three two one here
we go
why 50 minus 50 to 750 t minus 40 to 750
t minus
30 to 750 t minus 20
15
10
5 4 3 2 whoa uh why they smell good i'll
call it a hurry
okay course correcting do right
and we're making our way to about 775
775
looking to go do
96.50
yep 650.
no fires right had the blood will put
out the fires all right course
correcting do north
wamo
we are looking for 675 828 what is in
front of me
where are we right now seven seven nine
seven seven not what x 647 oh whoops oh
my god not 650 675 is what we were
looking for
my bad
got that wrong i better hurry this blood
seems to be rising
we're looking for 675
675 cone
firmed adjusting course and moving
and 675 has been achieved more straight
on should look for 675 828
all right we are just about on course
675 confirmed
ish 8
28 almost in the
bag 8 28 and 3 2 1 8 28 looking for
angle 295
295 confirmed beautifully
[Music]
all right okay um
well the expedition ultimately raised
more questions than answers satellite
images showed pieces of the sm-13
scattered all over the bottom of the
trench as though it had been torn apart
by some huge beast the wreckage cannot
be reached at this time no photographs
have been recovered the stars shine pale
as bones the moon is a lifeless corpse
its ocean a gaping wound the universe
what's left of it is dying but somewhere
in the void there must
be
well i don't know about that i'm dead
but maybe in another multiverse there's
some part of me that uh lives on to uh
go into the blood ocean another day
don't know why this is the fourth one
that they've explored but uh hey you
know what not bad that was actually
excellent that was incredible i really
loved that experience it's so novel it's
so interesting there's not like a super
direct thing that's threatening you it's
everything around you is threatening you
and it's constant and pervasive and any
game that can create a constant and
pervasive sense of death lurking right
outside a thin metal wall
is a pretty cool game in my book so
thank you everybody so much for watching
this has been iron lung link in the
description if you want to play this for
yourself i have an amazing series that
if you want to check it out called in
space with markiplier is very fun and i
think you'll like it link also in the
description or you can go to my
channel's front page more scary games
also in the description there's a lot of
stuff in the description why don't you
just check it out i also have podcasts
with bob and wade we do distractible and
with tyler we do go
my favorite sports team thank you
everybody for watching and as always i
will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you